hey 42 here of all the peculiar places
we've perused on this channel this is
quite possibly the least impressive
at least on the surface i mean it's a
field
but believe me this is no ordinary patch
of farmland
take that odd little cups of trees for
example isn't it strange that the farmer
never bothered to clear it you'd think
it would make working the field easier
and increase planting area
but it turns out the farmer never
touches that particular bit of land
in fact
he doesn't even own it
this specific circle of conspicuous
conifers in the center of a north
carolina field was quietly bought by the
united states army in 1961
which begs the question
why did the most powerful military on
earth
buy a random patch of turf
well it wasn't the land itself the army
was interested in
but what lay beneath
you see this seemingly nondescript field
in north carolina hides a terrible
secret
a secret that just over 60 years ago
almost murdered tens of thousands of
innocent americans as they slept
this is the story of the goldsboro
incident the scariest close shave in
history
i've always found maintaining my weight
to be a bit of an up and down experience
i eat a pretty healthy diet at home but
whenever i travel i tend to eat really
bad and i always return a bit heavier
and more sluggish than before so i took
the free 30 second noom quiz the links
in the description by the way or you can
go to noom.com42
and ever since things have turned a
corner for me what i love about noom is
that it focuses on maintaining your
health without depriving yourself of
treats and everyone's popular favorites
like pasta pizza etc every morning i
make sure to spend just five minutes
doing my daily noom lesson which over
time has actually changed my psychology
around food and my attitude towards when
i eat how much i eat and my choices i
quickly discovered after only a couple
of days of using noom that i was having
way too much for breakfast using noom's
food logger i realized that most days i
was consuming up to 800 calories for
breakfast alone
with neum i've been able to reduce that
to about 400 to 500 calories which
enables me to maintain my weight so much
easier i've just for example cut my
granola serving in half and replaced it
with a handful of blueberries which
makes it almost 300 calories less there
have been so many little tweaks like
that for me that have transformed the
way i eat because neum isn't a diet it's
a positive lifestyle overhaul based on
proven behavioral psychology techniques
so take your free 30-second quiz today
at
noom.com42 or click the link in the
description below to get started now
thanks to neem for sponsoring this video
just before midnight on the 23rd of
january 1961 three days after jfk was
sworn in as president a b-52
stratofortress strategic bomber was
docking with a refueling plane somewhere
over goldsboro north carolina mid-air
refuelling is a dangerous business but
these pilots were pros so there was no
problem
until there was a problem
the crew on the refuelling tanker
noticed that the b-52 was leaking fuel
from one of its wings the operation was
aborted immediately and the bomber's
pilot was advised to land at a nearby
air base post-haste the trouble was the
b-52 was too heavy to land safely it's a
little-known fact outside of aviation
circles
that most planes take off significantly
heavier than they're safely rated to
land thanks to the extra weight of a
full tank of fuel
the b-52 was no exception it's a
colossal craft capable of holding up to
150 000 kilograms of jet fuel
that's about 22 hefty african bull
elephants
which is the civil aviation authority's
official yardstick for jet fuel
i promise
anyway the plane was still laden with
fuel so the pilot flew a holding pattern
to burn some off before landing
but as the second slipped away
so did the oil
every minute thousands of liters fell
into the soil what initially appeared to
be a minor operational issue was now a
full-scale emergency
the pilot tried to land fervently but
the plane was damaged irreversibly
it was going down
and there was nothing anybody could do
to stop it
losing any aircraft is a big deal but
losing this particular b-52
was a potential global catastrophe
because bundled within the belly of the
bomber were two 3.8 megaton hydrogen
bombs each containing 200 times the
explosive force of fatman the nuclear
bomb that obliterated nagasaki
now before i get on to what happened
next you might be wondering just what
the hell the u.s air force was doing
flying hydrogen bombs over home soil
good question
and i can answer it with just two words
chrome dome
yes that's a playfully offensive term
for a bald man but it was also the very
silly name for a deadly black ops
mission run throughout the 1960s by the
u.s air force
chrome dome was what you might call a
doomsday program created with one simple
aim in mind to intimidate the soviet
state
remember this was the middle of the cold
war when nuclear tensions were at an
all-time high
world peace relied on a highly
sophisticated strategy
inspired by school playgrounds
if you blow me up i'll blow you up big
time
sounds good on paper
i think
but in practice the whole mutually
assured destruction thing had a pretty
serious flaw namely that if it ever came
to nuclear war
whoever landed the first blow would have
one hell of a first mover advantage
[Music]
suppose the soviets were able to destroy
or disrupt a significant portion of the
united states command infrastructure in
a single strike it could render a
retaliatory attack impossible
hence destruction was neither mutual
nor assured
and that's where chrome dome came in
this operation ensured multiple b-52
bombers armed with thermonuclear weapons
were in the sky at all times
that way even if the soviets bombed
north america back to a radioactive
stone age the president could still
reign fiery death on russia far from
home all thanks to chromedome
sure it was a solid plan
but allow me to paint a precarious
epigram
weapons that could murder millions were
being flown over the heads
of unwitting civilians
and that happened 24 hours a day seven
days a week for eight straight years in
the 1960s
sure flying is one of the safest ways to
travel but put enough aircraft in the
sky for long enough and eventually fate
will deal a fatal fluff
[Music]
which brings me neatly back to the 23rd
of january
1961 and our battered bomber plummeting
towards the ground alongside two of the
most powerful weapons ever built by man
the mighty plane broke apart as it fell
and the nukes were thrown clear
the first drifted slowly down to earth
after its integrated parachute deployed
but the second was speedier accelerating
to 700 miles an hour before smashing
into the ground with the force of a
meteor
as it happens only one of the two bombs
ever came close to detonating
and it's probably not the one you'd
expect the nukes were equipped with four
different safety mechanisms designed to
deter incidental detonation
in the case of the second bomb the one
that crashed into a field at close to
the speed of sound
these mechanisms worked exactly as
intended
as for the first bomb well
let's just say things played out a
little differently
probably presumed the parachute i
mentioned was some kind of safety
feature to protect the bomb in the event
of an accident
but in reality it was a key part of the
weapons detonation sequence
designed both to give a pilot time to
escape after dropping his payload
and to facilitate an air burst explosion
one where the bomb detonates at a set
altitude to ensure maximum destruction
on the ground below in other words the
fact that the first nukes parachute
deployed at all
was a very ominous sign indeed because
it was preparing to explode
when a bomb disposal team arrived at the
site the following day
they found the 3.5 meter 3 000 kilogram
weapon standing perfectly upright and
intact its tip buried in the ground
it was an alarming sight all round
although admittedly it was quite a bit
better than the alternative a giant
crater of death and fire
in the years after the incident there
was plenty of debate as to just how
close this weapon had come to exploding
publicly the us government played things
down claiming both nukes were
deactivated and that there was never any
risk to the public
it probably won't surprise you one bit
that this was utter [ __ ]
in 2013 a newly declassified report
revealed that three of the four safety
mechanisms built into the first bomb had
failed and that only an electrical
switch in the off position
had prevented a firing signal from
reaching the nuclear core
in other words a solitary switch is all
that prevented a full-scale detonation
one that would have killed tens of
thousands of sleeping americans in an
instant
and risked the lives of millions more
through nuclear fallout
it's worth pointing out that despite
dodging a nuclear apocalypse the
goldsboro crash was by no means
victimless
there were eight servicemen aboard the
bomber when it went down
eight servicemen but only six ejector
seats
three of the crew died
though remarkably one of those not in an
ejector seat lieutenant adam mattox
somehow managed to survive by flinging
himself out of the plane's top hatch and
deploying his parachute
to this day this big bald badass remains
the only person in history to have
bailed out of a b-52 cockpit without an
ejector seat and live to tell the tale
in the days and weeks after this nearest
of misses disposal work commenced
the first bomb that almost murdered
thousands proved to be the easiest since
it was still in one piece
so they used an incredibly complex atom
bomb disposal
technique they picked it up and stuck it
on the back of a big lorry
very very carefully but things were a
bit trickier when it came to the other
bomb
having smashed into a swampy field at a
smidge under the speed of sound the
three-ton weapon had burrowed six meters
into soft ground
tearing itself apart in the process
the bombs contained two separate nuclear
cores a piece to ensure maximum
destruction on detonation
the recovery crew quickly located the
first and largest of these cores but the
second was never found despite calling
in a fleet of industrial excavation
vehicles
after weeks of fruitless digging a
decision was made for the hole to be
refilled and flattened and basically
pretend the whole thing never happened
as you might have guessed by now that
lost core is the little secret i
mentioned at the start of this video
to this day a six kilo rod of
weapons-grade plutonium
lies somewhere underneath those trees
that's why the u.s army purchased that
particular patch of property to ensure
nobody ever forgot what lies beneath and
decided to
build a house on it or something else
really stupid
remarkably the rest of the field is
still farmed to this day
what's also remarkably stupid is that
the us air force was well aware of the
issue that brought the bomber down that
fateful night
boeing had figured out that a recent
modification they'd made to the wings
could under certain conditions caused
them to literally tear off
i'm no aviation expert but
i think that's pretty serious
the bomber in question had already been
booked in for a refit to fix the issue
but apparently the air force decided
that ferrying nuclear weapons across the
northern hemisphere was a totally
reasonable thing to do in the meantime
and well the rest is history in some
ways you could say this story is a bit
of a non-event
i mean aside from the tragic loss of
free crew members
nothing actually happened
and yet for my money the goldsberg
incident is one of the most fascinating
sliding doors moments in history
a single electrical switch decided the
fates not just of millions of americans
but very possibly
the entire world after all a 3.8 megaton
hydrogen bomb exploding on american soil
in the middle of the cold war could
easily have had some
dire consequences
if the americans thought they were under
attack the response would have been
immediate and devastating and even if
they realized the nuke was one of their
own
would the american government really
have admitted to accidentally murdering
tens of thousands of its own citizens
or might jfk on his first week in the
job remember
have been tempted to point the finger at
the old soviets next door
i guess we'll never know
thanks for watching
[Music]